malcolm gladwell what's your new book
about
it's called david and goliath um
underdogs
misfits in the art of battling giants
and it's about
underdogs uh i got really interested in
telling the stories of
people who seem weak and powerless
and yet go on to accomplish great things
and i i that was a puzzle of how they
managed to do that
that i thought was worthy of a book and
so this is my latest
well back in 09 you wrote a piece for
the new yorker
yeah david versus goliath about uh and
i'll let you tell the story but
is that what's when your interest
started yeah i wrote a story although
weirdly that none of the
nothing in that article i wrote for the
new yorker made its way into the book
but it was what got me
thinking about it um it was an article i
wrote about a guy
started with a story of a guy who he was
an indian indian immigrant
living in silicon valley he starts to
coach his daughter's basketball team
and they're all 12 13. and they're all
the daughters of
software engineers from silicon valley
and they they don't
they can't pass shoot dribble
they can't do anything that resembles
basketball and so he decides what
they're going to do is
play maniacal defense they're going to
play they're going to have the full
court press
100 of every game and
that proves so devastatingly effective
that they go all the way to the national
championship
and so the idea was that he responded to
a weakness the fact that they had no
basketball skills
by adapting and by adapting in a way
that proved to be pretty devastating
and also by breaking the rules because
people don't expect
12 year old girls to play the full court
press in fact it's a little bit
unsporting because
you know the skill level is such at that
stage and if you play the press no one
can bring the ball up the court
right so it's sort of this really
interesting example of someone
who chose to rather than remain passive
in the
face of some kind of weakness to
to adapt and that's that
adaptation is what really this book is
about about
what are the strategies people use to
respond to their own shortcomings
what's one of the examples and that you
use in the book well i'm really
interested for example in
talking about dyslexia i have a whole
chapter on
why are so many successful entrepreneurs
dyslexic
it's a neurological problem it's a
deficit it's a
a part of your brain is not working
properly i mean it's nothing you would
wish on a child
and yet in one case after another many
of the
most famous entrepreneurs we know have
lived their whole lives with
this devastating disorder and if you
talk to them will tell you
that they succeeded not in not in spite
of this disorder but because of it
that it taught them something about how
to deal with the world
that proved to be incredibly valuable in
their career
and that's uh uh there's something
very beautiful about those and very
moving about those kinds of stories
and i tell a couple of them about um and
it's a beautiful illustration of this
sort of
paradox i'm interested in describing
which is that very often we learn more
from
our disadvantages than we do from our
advantages
malcolm gladwell is there any connection
between david and goliath the tipping
point
outliers well you know i wish they were
i wish there was some
grand unfolding narrative so i could
argue that if you own one you had to own
them all
but but i i don't think there is i think
that they're just
they simply they happen to be what i'm
interested in at the time and they
i suppose are all answers to the
question
um why does the world surprise us
why does the world not work the way we
expect and that's the theme i keep
coming back to
how long do you sit with an idea
a long time i mean i think about a book
for
years before i start writing it um
i don't think if you're going to ask a
reader to commit
a big chunk of their life to your book
you have to
corres correspondingly commit a big
chunk of your life to that book in other
words you cannot
expect people to make the investment and
you if you don't take your time
and so i take i thought about this one
and collected
ideas for years before i started writing
some of the dave and goliath stories
that we've heard are military stories
the viet cong
versus the u.s army are those included
at all in new york
well i start the book starts with me
retelling
the actual david and glass story
which is not what you think it's very
different in reality than
has been and then i tell a story from
vietnam about a guy
who understood very early on that the
vietcong was not who we thought they
were
that they weren't going to give up
easily and no one would listen to him
and it's because the military was not
the american military in those years
was not like like all of us
i think had difficulty with the notion
that someone could be
without obvious strengths without money
men
weapons anything and still be a
formidable opponent
and that's what my book said my book
says the opposite that
don't be fooled by the armor someone is
wearing
what matters is the man inside the armor
how did the tipping point change your
life
well i mean i suppose it just put me on
the map as a writer
um and so it it paved the way for the
success of my other books
it didn't change me personally
it just made my life my professional
life a little easier
people i suppose return my phone calls a
little faster than they used to
but it didn't turn me into a different
person
which i'm thankful so it just was a kind
of
such a bizarre and happy
accident that that book did so well that
i've been i'm just grateful ever since
do you look at your books or do people
look at your books as perhaps
self-help books or business primers
well you know all great books are
self-help
self-help books in that they they
encourage us to look more closely at
ourselves and what we think and how we
behave and um
so in that sense they are they're not
how to change your life in seven easy
steps
but um the reason i write them is i want
people to
take a step back and say and just
rethink their own experience to say
oh i hadn't that had not occurred to me
or oh that's how i make sense of that or
that sheds a whole new light on
something that's happened to me or
someone i know
malcolm gladwell there's a reason
goliath or goliath and that's because
they've been successful
how do they maintain their success well
that's a great question
the first half of my book is devoted to
the ways in which goliaths shoot
themselves in the foot
that the acquisition of success sows the
seeds for
failure um and breaking out of that
cycle is very very difficult
you know every single day we look around
this and we see once mighty institutions
falling i mean the camera that is
recording the show is by
sony sony was once the mightiest
electronics company in the world
last year they lost i read this in the
newspaper yesterday 8.5 billion dollars
and some people say they should shut
down their electronics division i mean
that's happened in 10 years they've gone
from the top of the heap
to a situation where people say openly
they should pack it in you know this
country we talk about vietnam there has
never been
a individual country as powerful as
america was
in 1964 and what happened over the next
10 years in vietnam we were humbled
right so i mean
there's uh the the
uh there is something um i think
uh profoundly humbling about what
happens to giants
to goliaths and um there
to be someone in position of great
authority and power is a more precarious
uh position than i think most people
realize
why do goliaths shoot themselves in the
foot
well there are many reasons um
i explore just a couple
one is they assume the same strategies
that made them great
will keep them great um
and that's not true and the two is they
underestimate
just how useful uh struggle was
how creative it made them when you don't
have enough
when your business could shut down
tomorrow
when you're constantly at the very
end of your wits you
you know i mean some cases you fold and
die but if you don't
you you learn how to be innovative
and to take chances and to take risks
and do all kinds of things that
you're propelled to do all kinds of
things you wouldn't ordinarily do
when you get comfortable you're no
longer under that compulsion
and that is a huge um
uh that's a huge transition that many
organizations or individuals can't make
they simply they forgot how useful their
own
their old disadvantage was
are there lessons to be learned for the
american political system from david and
goliath
uh you know i was a canadian i'm always
very wary of ever
holding forth on the american political
system i'll only say this i don't know
that there
are you know i i'm in a minority on this
but as someone
who's not from this country i'm always
impressed at how
good our political system is i think
look around the world is there one that
you would trade for american system i
mean
none of them are perfect ours isn't
perfect it's pretty good
we're all pretty happy with it we all
pay our taxes we don't leave
and people want to come here so it's
like i don't think there's anything i
could teach the system the system as far
as i could tell is doing a pretty good
job
are you a citizen now no i remain a
canadian i i can't give up my
i can't give up my canadians malcolm
gladwell when does david goliath
hit the stands uh beginning of october
october 1st
of this year 2013. and this is book tv
on c-span 2
previewing malcolm gladwell's newest
book
david goliath october 2013 is when it
hits
the bookstores thanks for watching book
tv